welcome to this video playing Moscow
clean or something I'm sorry I'm having
a little snack IAM on the moon thought
maybe age 40 k is going for the solid
line with c6 yeah blackest black is very
solid here h for some not particularly
great move in the structure of course i
would rather have it on h3 but okay it's
some sloth exchange type of position and
soap knee okay for white um surprises me
a bit toasty five such a weakness that
you need to spend and move on that not
sure okay maybe maybe go here at least
now is e 6 plate he cannot really take
on e5 hmm as it sets up this pin 95 d 5
h six maybe
ok
yeah h4 is always very irritating and
this is move this move is on the board
still maybe I should just casts on him
or take and then castle you can try
after be takes which I'm expecting have
to be take some I can play castle so
that c5 can be answered with nine a form
yeah it's nothing nothing great really
oh now this I didn't expect okay I
thought that this might be not that
great because it feels like I'm gaining
some time here now I'm threatening um
okay no I'm threatening a thought bishop
of 694 but here of course um this is not
not doing anything great I can play
Queen B 5 may be threatened to take and
I'd be five hi it's still very little
very little as some probably to worm to
positive this basically nothing
happening again the bishop 1g5 can
easily turn out to be offside
so I'm going to take it on f6 and night
yeah we have night against bishop but
the pawn structure is very symmetrical
it's not a very favorable normally for
them for the bishop side okay take here
and watch now Queen a 392 maybe and
gaining a temple on the bishop and then
92 to and get them to be a bit quicker
on the C file
yeah for once it's a very very equal
pollution I wonder if I can do something
here does some way to make any headway
even night f4 maybe something rook c8
though just um adjust the trade
Queen g3 something that I cannot really
enter them yeah that's really nothing
nothing great possible
yeah exchange between f6 but is really
nothing nothing going on maybe here yeah
now you start with such an enterprising
looking line with h4 then you get this
this this boring position yeah it's just
um not much happening I wonder if I can
do something something with this with
the Queen and night against the Bishop
g4 g5 something it's probably not very
realistic
maybe Knight to f3 it can be five at
some point yeah it's still equal there's
not much not much else to be said about
it I do something g45 is probably not
great time worries i'm not sure i don't
want to sit around all the time and it's
probably had probably the right would be
the right way to go about it Oh
interesting the end game
night again submission but he's got some
porn weaknesses nothing serious but
yeah it's probably still about equal I
believe that can be can be tricky can be
tricky now with the Jeep on you to try
to quickly get rid of all the pawns
check
oh no he's got the he's got the right
Bishop here Shasta that's a very big
problem white markings on time ah no ah
this feels bad i mean this end game is
somewhat worse for me but I shouldn't
lose it what did I do wrong here of
course yeah I should play before yeah
the thing is I was irritated by bishop p
1 thought okay i cannot move the night
but i don't need to i can just mix the a
pawn something like this and then be
five yeah the statuses are drawn this is
a drawer really so i should do that and
again before always bishop you won i
thought yeah the key opponent game is no
problem of course this is terrible this
is a terrible King e2 was just terrible
and probably losing ah this was bad yeah
here this is a fairly straightforward
drawn because i can i can just move my
pawn and and this is no no problem i can
stop one point easily tear the plane
yeah i was always irritated by bishop e1
and i simply forgot that i didn't i
didn't really realize that
he and does not threaten to take the
night jack this is this is now lost he
enters with the king I have no way to
stop that yeah or this sem this is the
same thing now i cannot move the pawns
and the jeep on will run and he's got
the right color the right caliber ship
jim from a practical sense maybe i
shouldn't play any form but wanted to do
something o 95 is of course strong oh
what a terrible game it gets worse and
worse i really shouldn't look at this
anymore I didn't see anything in this in
this bloody game here white is just
better of course see 597 he must take
and this is a very favorable end game
maybe it's even winning for white with
the space advantage the two weaknesses
and i have several tempe in reserve to
form hmm i winning or not maybe it is
just so wrong the c5 king coming to d5
probably just the wrong okay thanks for
watching